foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS moving and storage Studio it's
the Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work they love and
create actual real relationships I am
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz hosting
today with fellow rooms and personality
and best-selling author Dr John deloney
so give us a call it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we're gonna go straight to the phones
this hour and Stan in Albany is up first
hey Stan welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing we're doing well
thanks for asking how can we help
uh yeah first want to give a shout out
to my brother-in-law for introducing me
to Money Makeover it's changed my life
um I'm on baby step two I'll be able to
pay off all my debts in complete maybe
step three my six month fund by the end
of December
23. thanks uh I'm married just over a
year have a three month old
I'm working full-time have two other
part-time jobs hey hold up hold up real
quick you just said uh
we're hyper
um attentive to a specific trigger words
and here's one of them you said you're
working hard to pay off your debts and
then you said you're married
is uh I I'm I'm gonna get into it but
I'm the sole Financial provider for the
household okay okay uh my wife works but
uh that's something we're not really on
the same page about just yet I know
we're married already and
we didn't really figure that part out
yet hold on hold on so she works and she
keeps all of her paycheck
yes and you're paying
all the bills and everything for your
for
um well until we figure things out I
told her that I'm not willing to pay for
her student loans that she brought into
the relationship in her auto loan
those are pretty much the only that's
that I know of that she has I don't know
how much they are really
how long have you been married
uh a year and three four months okay but
I just I'm I want to clarify this Stan
though that do you pay for for your
family's life though like it's not like
because for some couples that have
separate finances you know some pay the
utility and the cable and the food and
the other is the mortgage and all that
provide everything I provide everything
okay
yeah and it's yeah and I'm gonna kind of
get into it yeah we'll let you keep
talking yeah yeah so I'm working full
time I have two other part-time jobs
that I'm working on my average take home
after taxes is like 8 300 to 8 700 a
month okay
um I mean again I'm acting as a sole
Financial provider for the household
um I currently live in well we currently
live in a paid for two bedroom one and a
half bath town home uh the rent and the
utilities are paid for like it doesn't
come out of my pay so the 83 the 8700
that's what I truly take home each day
who pays for them each month uh so
that's part of my full-time job
management agreement for the property I
manage the property and it's part of my
agreement with them okay on my
compensation okay uh which is which is a
big plus yeah so that's what kind of
leads me to I know we got to talk about
the marriage and finances but my big
question that I called about here was
how long can I really stretch this out I
mean given how advantageous the
situation that I have uh I have the
ability to update the unit with a
finished basement a full bath to meet
our needs as we grow as a family as we
have another child uh and if I could I
mean if it was up to me I'd live here
forever you know what work are you doing
are you working for like an HOA what
work are you doing
no no I'm a real estate manager
for like a like a real estate company
and this is they just give you one of
these their homes yeah it's a family
company I'm self-employed I mean I I'm
employed by the company I have my own
company as well so your mom and dad
uh different family members yes yeah
okay
okay so you're so your big question is
what stated again so so I mean it's an
ideal situation I wanna if I could I
would stay here forever yeah uh I mean
it's a more than ideal situation for
maximizing what I can throw at Building
Wealth retirement college fund Etc okay
I really want to know like how long can
I really stretch this out for
um
I guess
the living situation I mean yeah it's I
mean to answer that question Sam I mean
you can stretch out as long as you as
long as you want I mean we talk to
people that are in New York City and
they're in a two bedroom with three kids
and you know what I mean like I mean you
can you can do that as as long as
possible because uh it sounds like from
the living situation if everything's
good with the family and it sounds like
it's part of your management agreement
all of that that all makes sense
Rachel would you finish out would you
put a bunch of money in a house that you
don't have any equity in
to finish out the basement and all that
uh no I nothing would come out of my
pocket so the house is like brand new
it's a brand new town home uh and yeah
if I did the upgrade to finish the
basement uh put another full bath in the
basement and then the second bedroom put
a full bath in there and the business
come out of my pocket okay the business
pays for it yeah and the business is
paying for where you guys live now yeah
yeah so the the reason you're calling
and asking this question means that
either you or you're
one foot in one foot out spouse doesn't
want to live there much longer probably
her
um
no I mean she hasn't said like how much
longer uh I think the one for one foot
out is more so in relation to again the
finances yeah uh I mean she chooses when
she wants to contribute I said I don't
know that's not kind of how I want to
live I mean you're either all in or not
I mean I've only been listening to you
guys for a month here but I mean I'm
hooked and the books change my life yeah
and to give her you know to give her a
little credit stand I mean you know he
you know you just came in one day and
was like I'm learning all this new stuff
let's get get on board and let's do it
like she probably is a little whiplashed
of like whoa this isn't the guy that I
believe there's the get out of debt
Whiplash but there's not the I'm gonna
work and I keep all of mine you pay for
everything in the house that's not
Whiplash no but it is if that's how
they've been functioning for a year and
a half of marriage and then last month
he comes in and she's like whoa why are
you changing everything so she's
probably like what's going on yeah they
should have this conversation before
they got married I know 100 ideally but
how much does she make Stan
uh she's a pharmacist so I think she
makes she makes probably over a hundred
thousand
oh wait and you don't even know really
what she makes though huh no yeah no it
is y'all you said you had a kid together
yeah okay yeah three month old okay
um okay I mean we're going to therapy we
started going to therapies yeah that's
great I think that's great we had
problems that started because of
I believe that we're not clear on
finances between yeah I believe it
absolutely okay so from the house
standpoint I would say I would I would
follow the baby steps so I would get out
of debt like you said you're going to at
the end of the summer get a fully funded
emergency fund and then for you guys as
a family it is a great step to go and
purchase a home on your own have a good
down payment all of that so that you're
building the equity to your point John
but relationally Stan that's a that's a
much bigger this marriage does not go
very far unless you all get on the same
page ASAP so hold on the line and
Austin's gonna pick up we're gonna give
you a year of Financial Peace University
and see if she will go through it with
you so you guys can get on the same page
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
you know
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Dr John
deloney and hey you guys if you have
found the Show recently or you've been a
long time listener one of the best ways
to spread the word Beyond just us being
out there on the airwaves and podcasts
and all the things YouTube is for you to
share the show so if you love it please
tell your friends and family about it
this has been something that has really
helped us get the word out more and more
because we want to see people become
financially free you want to see people
have healthier relationships and more
because people love their jobs more than
helping us it helps your neighbor who's
never heard of this yes when you're
sitting at home wondering how do people
get in all those credit card debts
because they don't they literally don't
know they're just doing what they were
told and this helps when you when you
like it and share it kicks it up in the
algorithms and it just it offers the
show to more random people yep that's
right that's your neighbors out exactly
that's it so we want to see this message
of hope that we talk about every day on
the show to be out within your family
within your community and within your
friends so make sure to share the show
again that helps us out so so much all
right up next we have here we go so
yeah from Orlando
from Orlando
welcome to the show hey guys how's it
going good how are you thank you so much
good you guys did well Jean-Pierre Jean
yeah so close so close great name though
thank you thank you I I was just calling
because I'm a long time listener love
you guys I I guess I have a question I
have I'm currently a full-time graduate
student and I I was working full-time up
until the point when I started graduate
school a year ago so when I was working
full-time prior to starting school I was
investing like in a 401k I didn't have
any debt so don't have any debt
thankfully and uh
I guess I'm thinking now because
everything you see is invest young
because compound interest and whatnot
and now that I'm not investing anything
this I guess I can't help Shake in the
back of my mind am I hindering what I'm
going to be able to do in the future as
far as investment because I didn't
continue investing during these years or
I'm not in school yeah I'm in school I
should say yep it's a great question
because there is very much this urgency
type of you know wording that people use
when it comes to investing because
because mathematically it is true right
when you look at the math you're like oh
my gosh like yeah the earlier you start
the better off you're going to be but
you because how old are you
I'm 27. 27 okay and how much longer is
grad school
I have two more years okay so you won't
start really probably picking back up
investing until 29 30 years old
yes that's right yep and from that point
on you're gonna be fine you're good
brother you are you are totally fine
what you're doing right now honestly is
the smartest thing because if you're
ever doing something big like higher
education if you're in school uh we
always say hey pause save up cash and
make sure that you can get through it
debt free because a lot of life can be
thrown at you in this and we don't want
you taking out student loans and all of
it so so what you're doing now is what
we would say quote unquote investing in
yourself right yeah you're part of your
portfolio yep so that's right instead of
dumping it into a 401 you're just
dumping it into jump here yep and so and
that's that's the wisest thing to do
honestly for the present and then when
you get out and you start working and
you have no debt you have cash stayed up
for an emergency fund you can press play
and invest 15 of your income into
retirement and you are going to be just
fine trust me and this isn't even math I
did the exact same thing you're talking
about
actually on several occasions
so you're good to go
me and my wife are doing fine
that's super good to hear I appreciate
that perspective from both of you yeah
you're good man the fact that you're
even asking this question and thinking
about it that tells me you're gonna be
all right I'm congratulations man I know
I do love the calls and we'll even get
some teenagers 18 19 year olds in here
and then the people in their 20s and
they're like freaking out because yeah
they're doing this or they're trying to
pay off the head like but what about
retirement I'm like thank you for even
asking because I read a stat that was
something like how 75 percent of
Millennials won't have enough for
retirement or something it was something
crazy uh the other day and the fact
again that you're asking these questions
and you're aware to even do it you're
gonna be fine so thanks so much for the
call all right up next we have uh
Brayden in Memphis Tennessee hey Brayden
welcome to the show
hey Rachel hey John how are you how can
we help question I got a quick question
for you so I'm 22 my wife is 23 and we
actually paid our house off about uh
eight months ago wow so congratulations
thank you so we actually
um are thinking about selling it now
um we've got a pretty good bit of equity
in it and so it's been on the market and
now that we have several people
interested in it
um I'm kind of chickening out because we
inherited some land on 100 acres
so we were planning on building but now
that everything just seems so unsteady
um it's kind of scary to
um sell the house and go into this build
because the plans that my wife has had
drawn up she we're going to have to
borrow about 120 000. so my question to
you is should I still sell this house
and is it okay for me to take this 120
000 loan to build a you know a pretty
nice house
sure okay so how much is the house worth
how much is the current the current
house yeah the house that you would sell
270. 270 okay
and how much you guys make a year
um we're making about 120. 120 good for
you guys
um I mean yeah when it comes to
especially right now building a home I
would get multiple bids talk to multiple
Builders because people the pricing in
it is going to vary greatly obviously
depending on probably their work and
customization but also the materials
they use all of it so I would go and and
definitely bid out and making sure that
you get you're getting the price that
you want and yeah I'm I'm fine with you
selling and taking out taking out a
small loan to be able to do this but I
would still follow what we talk about
here at Ramsey
um that when it you'll get the building
alone and then when it turns into your
your monthly mortgage payment making
sure that it is still less than 25 of
your take-home pay and that you guys
have cash set aside for an emergency
fund that you're still walking the baby
steps in this process
we have about I have about 105 000 saved
up
um so we're going to be filling that
with the 270 so it's going to be more
like
um you know around a half a million
dollars is what we'll be building for
um so after I set back I guess 25 for
emergency fund um the thing is it mainly
scares me is that being on that
um variable rate for construction loan
you just kind of don't know what's going
to happen in the process of building
Braden
um
you all paid your house off eight months
ago so the first the first month after
you pay that off it's kind of weird in
the second month you just go kind of go
crazy
the third fourth fifth month how has
that felt
oh it's been awesome like you have no
bills right
yeah no bills so what I have found in my
life um the couple of times I thought
I'm just gonna go how much do I qualify
and then when they tell me how much I
qualify then I start looking for houses
in that that General vicinity right
before I was uh like all in on the
Ramsey plan
I spent way more I had projected in my
house to spend way more for a house than
I would have if I had x amount of
dollars to go spend on a thing
and so you have drawn up plans for a six
for a 500 000 house you've you've got
cash you've got Equity you're gonna have
all this money
man when they come to you and show you
what they could do with the front yard
and with the pool that that 120 000 can
go to 300 000 without even
without you even sneezing yep there's
something different about what if you
and your wife said we want to do this we
inherited the land the land's not going
anywhere construction rates are a mess
the the everything's up and down and
sideways what if we pretended we were in
baby step two again and we saved up 120
000 over the next two years and we
walked in with this much dollars to
spend and it gave us absolute yeah I'm
telling you right now your anxiety is
going to be way way lower because you've
got a here's how much we can spend and
contractor who's going to be needing
work here's how much we got for you and
um then you're going to be able to walk
into a new place debt free you see what
I'm saying there's no sure because
there's no rush there's no rush and you
guys are still young it's not like oh my
gosh we gotta we're gonna retire and
have to pull money out you know there's
not any of that conversation going on
um so yeah even if you guys just pause
for two three four years with your
income John's right you could save it up
and then you have this uh absolute
figure in your head before it doesn't
start to creep up because
Renovations it creeps so uh thanks so
much for the call Braden this is the
Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show so one
of the I don't know Pros or cons of
living in 2023 with social media is you
see everything you see all different
types of
advice and I know I'm an old man but I
sure miss the days when I just didn't
know what was going on I know I know but
when it comes to money I mean
relationships gosh on there's like so
much there all over for your line of
work but with money there everyone feels
like a financial expert these days and
they all have like their little shortcut
or like their thing that you need to do
the hacks oh yeah figure it out and it's
and it's it feels like it's everywhere
so uh James our producer came across
this video we watched it and I was like
Yep this is what's out there so I
haven't seen it yet so I'm like let's
address it so James go play it
parents instead of kicking your kids out
at 18 keep them home until they're 25
and charge them 250 dollars per month
for rent when they turn 25 give that
money back to them that would be almost
21 000 then they can use that as a down
payment for their future home trust me
your kids will thank you
just like Billy Madison
everyone in the room is no Dumber for
what we've heard oh my God
wow okay let me start off on the
positive note since I'm like all right
positive Penny over here I'm negative
Nelly this week so go ahead the idea the
motivation the concept of hey help your
kids save and wonderful let them have
some money for a down payment yes
yes absolutely
secretly doing it by forcing them to
live at home and pay rent and then
Keeping a Secret account that you're
gonna yeah and then suddenly here it is
no because no no on many reasons
we're not mad at grown adult I'm not
I'll speak for me I'm not mad at grown
adults living with their parents for a
period of time if there is a life
transition that is happening you've
moved to the city where they are and you
want to live there for a bit uh whatever
it is right there are reasons and again
great reasons for adult children to move
back home for a period of time right and
not for this nebulous oh I'm just saving
money on rent until 25. I'm going to
just keep going yeah no no no for a
period of time with an end date very
specific all of it because there is such
power when you're a young adult when
you're 22 23 and you're having to figure
out the world
there's just D I mean there's something
in that dignity there's this idea that I
have to Now problem solve and I can't
just you know fall back on my parents
and those lessons and skills that you
learn through problem solving are what
you lean on when you're 30 and 40 and 50
and through the rest of your life so if
you it's like
um
I'm going to teach you how to do to
bench press and I'm going to get under
the bench press bar and I'm going to
push it up for you and then you help at
the very end and then at the end I'm
gonna tell you clap for you tell you how
strong you are if you're robbing your
kid of is
um strength yeah like the the steps you
have to take the day in and day out
stuff I mean it's just it's a long-term
game and I'm all for I'm all for Rachel
not only going home for a season that's
great yeah I'm also if you're have have
put yourself in a position if you've
gotten lucky in life if you've taken
care of your money and you've handled it
well
I can think of no more awesome gift than
at my kid's wedding to hand them a set
of keys or to say
I I got you a house for Chris like for
for your wedding or whatever yeah or
your down payment for your home I love
to do that yeah it'd be amazing to be in
that position to do that but I'm not
going to trick you that's right and I'm
not gonna like reverse you know you live
with me for seven years till you're 25
and then I'm gonna sneak 20 000 but that
just come on that just doesn't work I
know so again the concept of helping
your kids
understand money and letting them save
all of it yes we are all for that but I
mean it's kind of the secrecy or the
trickery or the like and and they're not
even into your point I'm like they're
not learning to save they think they're
paying rent so then when they go off on
their own at 25 they have no like
ability to know how to delay
gratification because they haven't been
doing it I'd rather sit down and teach
them how investing works and if they
wake up at 25 and they've chosen not to
put 250 in an account yeah
um then that's the choice they've made
that's right that's right and there is
such a fine line with enabling oh yeah
we talk about it all the time and a
blessing right because like you said I'm
like yeah if you have the ability and
your kids are at a place where you feel
like yeah emotionally they can handle
it's not going to damage them to do
something crazy like buy them their
first house or a down payment on their
first out like right like you could do
stuff and we talk about changing our
family treats that kind of stuff because
if you're if you don't ever have a
mortgage and you invest your mortgage
payment what would have been you're
changing your great great kids life
changes their kids I mean like yeah the
ball keeps rolling which is a amazing
and that's part of the freedom we want
that money isn't this thing that is so
burdensome burden burdensome here you
know in our in our lives and but again
so what's the balance of that John
versus it bleeding over into
I don't even want to say entitlement
it's more enabling this is an unpopular
sentiment and and we we do it innately
but then when the the the higher the
stakes get the more dramatic we get
about it uh one of my kids I got two one
of my kids I can say hey do you want
some ice cream and they'll be like yeah
it'd be awesome and I can give them one
scoop and they're like yes
if I give one of my other my other kid
like hey you want some ice cream
I will find them digging through the the
mini marshmallows at 2 A.M like right
and so one kid introducing sugar in a in
a in a certain context is enabling I'm
making a bigger mess one of my kids can
handle it so I think enabling the
balance is have I trained you and taught
you and have you demonstrated the
character to handle what I'm about to
the the gift slash burden I'm about to
hand you because it's both yeah can you
handle this and if you can't I love I
love you enough to not do that right and
so it's super fun to give something as a
parent it's not fun to withhold but the
right thing to do is you're not ready
for this
um then I'm not gonna do that okay so
let's talk about like a realistic
situation if there is a parent out there
and they're like yeah I have two grown
kids one can handle it one can't
do you give one in this extreme example
of a house like let's just go extreme do
you give one a house and one not I mean
the way I would frame that was since
they were little I would say
um you are making choices
and if you choose this and this and this
then you're choosing to enter into this
right yeah and often parents will say
like if you talk that way in this house
you're out of here I'm not going to
weaponize my relationship with my kids
in that way what I will tell my kids is
if you choose to be disrespectful to Mom
you're choosing to leave and the house
doesn't work well when you choose that
similarly if I have an adult child who's
I this is the same as we tell people
from California yeah but houses just
cost this much math is still the same
right and so my adult responsibilities
are still the same no matter how hard
the conversation is if I have an adult
child who I have to look at and say
you've made these choices I so therefore
you've opted out of this blessing I was
going to put in front of you and
I'm not gonna hold it I took this from
you I didn't get no you chose you opted
out and you're an adult and you get to
do that yeah this is where we found
ourselves yeah yeah now if I'm gonna use
it for like you're coming to all my
Christmases or whatever then you're
doing it yes that's a that's a power
move and that's a whole other pathology
right a whole yes a whole other thing
there yeah yeah so I think that that
balance is one that I think a lot of
parents ask and want to know as you
start to raise your kids and it's like
yeah how do I how do I give them
blessings and we even talk about this in
our house and we have little ones seven
five and three but it's like
there's a point that yeah we want to
enjoy our lives and go to Disney World
or whatever the thing is and have fun
but also there's a a normalcy that we
want to create that's not that right so
at Disney World I think of somebody I
think if somebody like um let's take
LeBron James whose son is an outstanding
basketball player or one of his sons is
because LeBron James is so good at
basketball in in the NBA
it doesn't give his kid a pass on
learning all the drills right and so
there may be better coaches there may be
better access all that's great his son's
still got to do the hard work and so if
I am in a different financial position I
I've got more money than my parents did
when I was raised great the lessons that
my kids have to experience and learn
stay the same throughout it right yes
it's still consistent because they're
still going to be off
going to
you like it or not I'm training them and
building that up in them so that they
can survive the world is what's key so
so good John so so good this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so a lot of you have questions about
taxes and we get it because taxes are
confusing and to help you better
understand how to handle them let's
unpack a question from one of our
listeners our kids are in college and
have part-time jobs can we still claim
them as dependents if they're filing
their own tax returns so yes you can
usually claim your college students as
dependents on your tax return even if
they're filing their own tax return so
you need to check a couple of boxes
first so number one they must be a
full-time student and they need to
indicate on their return that they are
being claimed as a dependent on someone
else's taxes number two they must be
under age 24 at the end of the tax year
number three they must live with you for
more than half of the Year being away at
school doesn't count against this
requirements number four they must file
single not jointly and number five you
must provide more than 50 percent of
their financial support for expenses
like housing food clothes education
Medical Care all of that
so if you are confident about filing
your own taxes then head to
ramseysolutions.com tax there you'll
find Ramsay's smart tax with low upfront
pricing and no hidden fees or you can
connect with a Ramsay trusted tax Pro
like one of our endorsed local providers
again that's all at ramseysolutions.com
tax
up next we have Billy in Orlando hey
Billy welcome to the show
thank you absolutely how can we help
well
um so I got
um some life insurance when my husband
passed back in June of 22. I'm sorry and
yeah so I paid off all my debt
except my house
and um I also am eligible to get some
pension money from him when he was in
the union okay and so um I am still
working
but my income's like 2800 a month and my
house payment is 13.50 so I haven't paid
that off
so I still have like 278 000 I'm just
wondering should I pay off my house
um since it's like half of my income my
house payment is and
um also on the pension I'm trying I'm
deciding I have a couple options whether
they want to give me a monthly payments
for the rest of my life or um a payment
every month for 60 months
um and then that's it
so I'm just trying to decide what to do
especially about the house and what I
should do with the pension yeah
absolutely so you have 278
000 left of the inheritance that you got
yes okay and how much is that how much
is left on the house
uh 194
195. okay yeah and how old are you Billy
65 65 okay and you're working so you're
making around 30 35 000 a year
um and the pension how much is like 67 a
year
67 a year oh yes oh I'm so sorry yeah
yeah yes yes yes
um and how much is the pension
the pension if I take the 60 months of
payments of twenty nine hundred dollars
and I roll those payments into something
I don't pay any taxes on of course till
I take it out but if I have otherwise I
have they have to take 20 off the top
yes
and do you do you have any retirement do
you have any savings on your own okay
before 401K it only has 50 000 in it
though 50 000 okay
um are you in a job that you can
continue to work on for the next five or
six years
yep okay
uh how much is the house worth Billy
about two well
I think it's valued like at 270. 270
okay
um
so yeah so I mean obviously you have the
money
um to be able to pay off 194 000 and it
would be done and you can continue to
work and put money away and you'll get
money from this pension
um and all of it but I I do want to ask
the hard question Billy is is the home
um
something that you do when I you do want
to keep do you see yourself ever maybe
downsizing or moving to something else
foreign
I don't know I like the community I'm in
I'm in a gated community
um 55 and older okay so and I really um
and it's only like five minutes down the
wrong from my mom and dad who are in
their 80s yep yep okay no that's great I
just I just wanted to ask because we do
talk to some people whether it's you
know a relationship change whether
through a death or a divorce and they
have a big asset like a home and they
say man maybe I could for financial
purposes you know
downsize and do something different but
if that's not what you want to do right
now you're not we're not in like these
treacherous Waters necessarily
um where it feels like this is the only
thing you would have to do so that's not
that's not the case but it sounds like
if
um
she paid her house off today she'd have
eighty thousand dollars left from The
Inheritance that she can immediately
roll in so then she's got 130 Grand and
then she takes 60 months of these
payments so suddenly overnight she's got
a couple hundred thousand dollars in
retirement that's right and you've got
absolutely zero risk no liabilities
there's nobody coming to get your stuff
because
um you don't have any payments in the
world how does that if you can just snap
your fingers you look up and it's a
couple years from now you got a couple
hundred thousand dollars in retirement
you got no bills you're making 67 Grand
a year you're not going to be rich but
it feels like you'd be safe does that
does that feel right
right and then Social Security I know
um will be close to four grand a month
yeah yeah if you were my mom I would
tell you
I have no risks in liability so go ahead
and pay your house off take the rest of
that money put that into retirement
accounts and um let's let's roll the
same one this is the the pensions over
as well yes yeah yeah rolling those over
and getting as much of a lump sum as
possible if that ends up becoming a an
option for you Billy being able to do
that and all of this Billy there's a
there's a lot of nuts and bolts when it
comes to looking at your entire
Financial picture so I would recommend
sitting down with one of our smart
investor Pros just to look through and
say okay here's my entire Financial
picture because that's 65 to be able to
say hey yeah for the next you know 20 30
years that I have left what is it going
to look like what is my lifestyle need
to look like and being able to map out
uh the next couple of decades I think
will be really really helpful so if you
stay on the line Austin's going to pick
up and help connect you uh with someone
there in Orlando and that's that's all
that's always a helpful conversation
again because they're going to be able
to show multiple ways of what to do and
run those members with very specific of
what the Market's doing currently than
we're able to do here on like a three
four minute radio call so I'm sorry for
your loss Billy but yep uh definitely we
would we would recommend paying it off
uh just like John said and continue to
invest the rest of that inheritance
though so that you are making interest
off that money that you can start to
live off of I also want to um just
applaud you Billy if you were here in
the studio I'd give you a hug I I'm so
proud of you for being still it's so
hard when you get the lump sum of money
like that I feel like I gotta do
something with it I gotta do this thing
and we always tell folks take six months
take a year just to be still and that's
what you've done and now
um you're never gonna forget your
husband is never going to not be painful
but the fog is lifted a little bit and
you're moving forward you're saying
you're making plans for the next couple
of decades
and you bought yourself a significant
amount of Peace just because you were
still and so congratulations and
everybody out there who has a a big loss
in their life
sometimes the most important thing to do
and the hardest thing to do is to just
sit still for a minute and just exhale
for a minute and sit in it and the time
will come time will come time will come
yeah and so that we we I mean what would
you say even up to a year would you put
a time frame yeah that if something were
to if something big happens like a loss
a death and you get a big sum of money
just to allow yourself to grieve and
process what just happened without
having to make big financial decisions
the guy who's was my the guy who trained
me in crisis response Dr Young Andy
young he's a brilliant guy from Texas
um I also went to him when I had
experienced loss and his recommendation
do nothing for nine months to a year so
good don't change jobs don't change
houses you just sit just sit still so
smart there's just a difference when the
when the fog lifts so good and hey you
guys all those of you that are new
listeners out there
um and you want to Deep dive into the
Ramsay baby steps make sure to go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we're gonna help you
figure out what step you are on right
now and where you can learn all the
lingo and all the stuff that we talk
about here on the show but it is really
really helpful so again
ramseysolutions.com and click that get
started button for all you new listeners
thank you so much John great hour and
thank you America this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual real relationships hey guys I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsay personality Dr John deloney and
we are here to answer your questions
everything when it comes to your money
your relationships your work and your
life and it's a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
so up first this hour we have Christian
in Anaheim California hey Christian
welcome to the show
hey Rachel hey John first time calling
I'm a big fan I've been hearing about
you guys awesome
two weeks so far yeah
um I'm working I have a full-time jobs
um I'm making 35 a hundred
um but I have a debt of 68
um getting a little bit frustrated I'm
scared I don't have a savings right now
but um I'm working right now with the
baby steps um
um I still have uh 400 right now in the
emergency fund but um the big problem of
my debt is my car
um I've been watching videos I've been
watching all the videos from the Ranchi
show about the car problems that many
others have as well and the big problem
is that I own a loan of forty thousand
dollars oh what kind of car is it man
it's a Hyundai Santa Fe uh 2022 hybrid
um okay but um I bought it on zero miles
and SRP was 36
um I think it was 36 000 but the markup
here in California are extremely high
yeah and they added like five thousand
dollars above plus I five with the
negotiation to you know sure hey so
before we get going on the math and all
this how old are you brother
30 years old 30. all right yeah I'm
older than you I'm in my 40s okay
I want to tell you
the fact that you
walked over to your bathroom counter and
stared yourself in the mirror
and said this this change starts with me
dude I want to tell you and what you
when you when you first say that and
then you look at reality when you choose
to look at reality and you see how much
debt you have it gets scary and you feel
ashamed and you can't believe you put
you and your family in this position I
want to tell you I think you're brave
and I think you're really freaking
strong you're stronger than most the
people that you run around with
because you're willing to face something
that they won't and that's reality
and now it's just about coming up with a
plan I promise you I've done stupider
stuff with way with way more zeros than
what you've done okay and I want you to
know I'm Standing Tall in the back end
after the smoke is cleared and you're
gonna get there and I just want you to
hear me say it before we dig into the
math I'm proud of you okay
thank you man I'm proud of you yeah this
is
um the first time that you know that I
opened about my desk you know there you
go that's right
yes yeah you're not you're not an idiot
you're not a you're not broke this
isn't forever you screwed up and and
probably nobody nobody nobody sat down
and talked to you about how money Works
did they
no actually no I've been learning by
myself that's right you learn on the
street in YouTube man and so
congratulations for saying enough's
enough's enough I'm proud of you man
it's big time your grandkids aren't
going to go through this because of the
work you're doing right now brother and
that's Legacy change and that's that's
commendable man I'm proud of you
so um um you know um
car which is very important I'm open
right now um and uh the problem is that
you know it's under the water
um I check
um a couple uh sources and and I think
the lowest was ten thousand the highest
was uh fifteen thousand dollars so I
don't know how exactly should I approach
to this steps 15 15 000 is what you said
the highest you found underwater iPhone
underwater so okay okay I apologize okay
so so I'm sorry to interrupt you um my
loan is currently forty thousand dollars
uh and and yeah and I've been paying
about for what eight six months
something like that so it haven't been
in a year so it's still pretty car so
I don't know what to do right now sure
sure no I I I hear you and I hear the
the stress in your voice so
um so there's a couple couple of things
okay again Christian how much and I
think you said at the beginning of the
call but how much do you make a year
uh a year it's 58 58.50 yeah taking out
the taxes okay I make a monthly uh three
thousand five hundred dollars okay but
take home yeah it's 58 a year yeah and
what other debt do you have besides the
car
um
um I have uh credit cards and I have
loans and I have a student loan okay so
how much are all how much are how much
is each credit card how much do you owe
on each one
um the I have won it 2002 or two
thousand dollars and the only one is
four thousand dollars it's maximum right
now okay so two thousand four thousand
and then what were the other loans that
you have
and you said you have a few other loans
what are those
are personal okay and how much are those
because one it's four thousand okay
and the other one is
this one has three thousand okay
and the small one is 200 uh two thousand
five hundred dollars two thousand okay
okay so you have a two thousand two
thousand three thousand and then a four
thousand four thousand combined with
loans credit cards all that and then
your big car payment at the end uh your
your car I did not tell you I did not
tell you my students
it's how much
eleven thousand eleven thousand okay
okay
yeah okay so
Christian are you are you single
family married okay right okay so here
if I woke up in your shoes
here's what I would do I would I would
sell the car you're gonna have to take a
small loan for the difference and so
hopefully you can sell it for thirty
thousand and be underwater ten thousand
that was the lower end
um so we're gonna just we're gonna pray
for that or find somebody that you'll
you'll buy for buy it for thirty
thousand you could even take out a
little bit of us of us maybe it's a
thirteen thousand dollar loan because
you'll take three thousand of that go
get yourself a beater replacement to get
you through baby step two and so what
you're gonna start to do is start
working your way through these debts do
you have any money saved at all any
money that is not in retirement
no no not at all not at all okay so what
you're going to start to do Christian is
I want you to create a budget a monthly
budget and your income that is coming in
I want you to plan out exactly what
you're going to spend in every category
of your budget and this is everything
from food to electricity and you are
going to you're going to take your
lifestyle all the way down to just needs
so this is food shelter utilities
transportation and that's it survival
anything else Christian is going to go
towards the smallest debt of two
thousand dollars the credit card or the
personal loan whichever one you can
decide and you're going to pay it off
you're out and then you're going to go
and get two two extra jobs you're going
to work extra jobs on the weekends
you're gonna work extra jobs at night
and you're going to be so focused and so
intense at attacking the set and the
great thing is Christian there's all
these little ankle biters it's like two
thousand two thousand four thousand if
you focus your money and you cut your
lifestyle and you have this intense
moment you can start to pay this off
hold on the line Austin's going to pick
up to give you Financial Peace
University
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
so Dr John deloney's with me today as
we're hosting and one of the biggest
questions that we get or issues that we
get is when it comes to relationships
and money George Campbell and I did a
whole podcast the smart money happy hour
on this an awkward money conversations
that happen between friends and family
and all of it because it's just a part
of life and so when it comes to talking
to your spouse about money we've heard
every story you could imagine we've
heard every type of conversation you can
imagine because of our jobs and people
call in or tell us about them and so um
we made a top 10 list of the top 10
worst ways to talk to your spouse about
money well I think this does this come
from is is this our do we make this list
James or does this come from uh we made
it it's our list okay all right
recompiled it so you want to go every
other or you just take it oh we'll do
every other okay because I know you say
some of these too top 10 worst ways to
talk to your spouse about money number
10.
have aggressively asking uh how much did
that cost after they bought something oh
I've done that number nine okay so
here's what we're going to do that's the
worst you've never said that said the
most controlling person I know all right
number eight
oh gosh I said this exact one literally
I can buy a new guitar and then I see
the Public's receipt or the Costco
receipt and I asked my wife why do we
spend so much money on groceries it's
the worst
dude I'm gonna punch punch every man
that asks that
uh number seven you just need to get on
board with this plan again why do I get
all the controlling ones every other
because of this
how fate province
hey we need to get out of debt so I sold
your car
incredible
well Dave Ramsey says oh that is the
worst dude yes it's weaponizing the old
man all right um number four
oh geez I'm the one working so it's my
money or alternatively
you don't work so you don't get a vote
if somebody says that just walk out that
conversation's over just leave just
leave I'm the one working not worth it
oh man uh number three for husbands to
their wives
do you really need fat haircuts or do
you really need that
skin product do you really need that
makeup whatever it is fill in the blank
of the things that ladies spend money on
that men don't and they think or maybe
you need to cost that much maybe my wife
is the one that has those conversations
with me
oh man I like to I like to be beautiful
Rachel my wife does often say wow do we
need we need that huh that that's we
need four separate creams for those hats
um this is from the a call back to the
other day
um when there was somebody who
um
whose husband wouldn't wouldn't help pay
for the the delivery parts of the
delivery because in his words his wife
couldn't hold out for a few more hours
so she got an epidural or oh my gosh and
made her pay for the bill yeah she had
to pay for the bill this was like on
Reddit though because she got a
lactation expert she got um like had
somebody come in and help with you know
whatever and he was like hey you got all
these extra Frills you got to pay for
those oh
whoa extra
it's like a mascara and an epidural not
in the same category Frills dude frill
dude and last but not least I don't know
yeah I'm not seeing the ROI on your gym
membership
that's brutal whoa that's brutal that's
brutal
um but yeah hey these are real these are
real scenarios that we have that we have
encountered
in our not our personal lives not all of
them but also in calls so hey if if you
have if you if you've got a a thing that
you've said that is dumb to your spouse
and we've all said them
um when it comes to money or if somebody
has said a dumb thing to you go to the
comments in the YouTube section below
this this clip and just give it to us
please what you have said that you know
I shouldn't have said that or that
somebody said to you go for it because
there's gonna be some good ones we'll
read it at the end if we can get a if we
can get a live feed in here that's funny
uh okay but John couples fight about
money for multiple reasons
um I would say one of the big ones I see
is just different money Tendencies when
it comes to Jess even on basic things in
life one tends to save more one turn one
wants to spend more even what you spend
the money on it's like well I don't
value that well I value this and it's
just this like hodgepodge of bringing
who you are as a person to a
relationship and then to your money and
it creates a lot okay create a lot of a
lot of arguments a lot of fights yeah or
if you grew up in a house like I did
where money was a scary scary topic that
caused stress that's what I knew about
money and so I don't like to talk about
it it makes me I just don't like talking
about it
um that has shown up in my marriage
right yep yeah and also debt yeah this
is a big one shame yeah yes because not
only
mathematically and financially is the
stress there of oh my gosh we have to
make all these bills and no one can lose
a job and you're kind of just living on
the edge but what that creates in us and
you've talked about this a lot you've
heard of that last caller right yeah it
was just the anxiety and then this and
the shame and the guilt and the regrets
all of that is very real yeah and that
fear about what's going to happen to me
tomorrow yeah terrifying stuff and when
your spouse is
kind of not supportive in it too oh yeah
then it just it magnifies it all so what
would you say are a couple of ways that
you can talk to your spouse when it
comes to money that actually will be
productive
and helpful and not harmful I think
anytime you have a hard conversation
with somebody especially with your
spouse especially about money always
start with i and
if you start a conversation with you
need to you've done
it this is just an instantaneous body
response they have to they have to wall
up and go to war back with you because
they feel attacked
when I sit down and and I don't say
something like how much did that cost
but I wait until I'm calm and then I say
I'm feeling uncomfortable about fill in
the blank I get scared about money and I
take it out on when I see things like
grocery costs or something I I just have
this innate reaction can you teach me
about
how much groceries actually cost
um and but it's it's about me talking
about how I feel not about lobbying
grenades right so it's me going to the
mirror first I think that's important I
also think it's important to talk about
as a couple here's where we want to go
and we're going to reverse engineer
where we want to be and here's the
choices we need to make today so that we
can get there that's different than
still the truck idiot right or Dave
Ramsey says you gotta
hey we we both want to be able to make
sure our kids go to college and they
don't have debt like what do we need to
do today to start that program that's so
good because I think too the stress and
the fighting and the conflict all of
that it feels so present it's like
everything going on here and it almost
is like this not in a fairy tale way but
it's almost like a calming sense to be
okay we're not gonna stop focusing right
now on today like let's look at the
future what do we want right what do we
want and like you said out of that okay
so then what are the choices today
because but I feel like you it's so easy
especially if you're stressed with money
and you and your spouse are not on the
same page it is easy for it to be a
complete craft show of yeah of being in
the present and you can't you it's like
you don't even have the capacity to look
up and look to the Future yes so
something my wife tells me
um if you Googled ADHD my picture comes
up next to this and um this is something
that I got from the great Dr Gabor mate
but she said and my wife will tell me
often um when I'm walking out of the
kitchen with a bowl of ice cream and
gummy bears marshmallows on top she'll
just gently and quietly put her hand on
my arm and say don't forget to remember
and what she's reminding she's not
coming and saying I can't believe you're
eating that or you're gonna sleep
terrible feel like crap what she's
saying is
don't forget to remember how good you're
going to feel tomorrow if you don't eat
all of that and it's just a general
reminder that future John has to pay the
bill run up by President John right yes
and so I think sometimes when I'm
scrolling guitars she can I'm going to
buy something else I'm gonna buy
something else she can gently walk by
and say hey don't forget to remember
we got plans you and me right we got
plans down the road and um let's let's
make decisions today that are going to
help us in the future in the future and
look and that and that is
a level of peace that you can have and
start working as a team together
focusing on the future and making those
present decisions today it's really good
John this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsey Way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
with debt payments and now inflation
stealing more and more of your paycheck
we know that a lot of you feel like
you're drowning and you're scared to
death that you're not going to have
enough to take care of your family and
you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress you guys but one thing
that has to change is you have to be
able to say I've had it I'm done I'm
done living this way and now
I want to start new things with my I
want to start doing new things with my
money changing what I've been doing so
when you get to that point of change so
you said I'm willing to try something
new that means it is time for Financial
Peace University this is our nine lesson
course that will teach you how to beat
debt build wealth and it's everything
that you need to know about how to
handle money
nearly 10 million people have taken
Financial Peace University and they will
tell you that it is so worth it because
they don't worry about money like they
used to they are in control and you can
be too so decide that you are done
stressing about money and take control
start Financial Peace University today
at ramseysolutions.com FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com
FPU up next we have Nick in New York New
York hey Nick welcome to the show
hey Rachel hey John uh first time
calling and it's a pleasure to speak to
both of you absolutely well thanks for
calling how can we help
okay so um I was very lucky to find you
guys
um almost right after college and uh you
guys have turned me a little bit into a
financial planning addict I would say um
so basically I'm at a point in my life
where I just turned 30 uh last week and
um I'm in a home where I have the
opportunity to save
um pretty aggressively and my my five to
maybe seven year plan is to kind of
increase in house once I have a family
um and where I'm at you know the average
house that I'm kind of looking to get
into eventually would be like in the 600
to 700 range
um so my my main question is is there
ever consideration or or a situation in
which it would be okay to scale back the
401k contribution a little bit if I'm
pretty maybe ahead of where
um you know maybe the average person is
in that area
so that way I can kind of save up more
for
you know the upcoming more current
future before retirement
yeah I mean I would say my the black and
white answer is is yes because we talk
about baby step 3B which is actually
pausing retirement to save up for a good
down payment so we recommend that people
do that in general are you thinking that
you're are you wanting to save up for
the down payment are you thinking like
save up for the whole thing
so I'm um I already have a home right
now
um it's worth 400 and I have 240 left on
the mortgage
um so I don't I didn't know if slowing
down on the the retirement
um investment you know made sense if
it's kind of for a second home and it's
not just to get into the first home but
based on where I am with like certain
numbers I was kind of thinking maybe
it's okay to just slow a little bit on
retirement if I'm at a good spot and
kind of prioritize it here and now a
little bit more in the next couple of
years to you know kind of get into a
home that that would make sense for my
future family absolutely and you're
talking about your primary home right
when you not a second home yes so you
would sell the current home that you're
in roll over what you have in savings
with the equity and purchase a new home
here in the next few years that's what
you're thinking right
yep yeah exactly so yeah I I'm great
with that honestly because
um you know we we talk about and I'm
assuming you're debt free and have an
emergency fund
correct yes so yeah I'm I'm great with
that Nick um I think being able to to
put some momentum towards that home but
I would have a I wouldn't let this just
yeah go into the black holes yeah so
have like an end date that you know hey
in the next three years I'm gonna pause
retirement to save up for a big down
payment or maybe all of it you know
depending on if you can if you can pull
that off uh with the cell sell sale of
your home your current home uh but I
would have a I would have a pretty
strict timeline Nick so Nick I I did
this and
um when I was working at a job that I
had housing was part of the the the the
package and then when I took another job
and I had to save up my wife and I just
took uh two years to save up money so we
could put a huge Chunk in we were ahead
on our retirement which is fine
that two years turned into two and a
half years almost three years and when
then they started taking retirement back
out it felt like someone was stealing
from me and so have a firm number I
would love to see you pause and maybe
Sprint and pay your house off that you
have right now something like that then
be putting money one place over on in
your left hand put some money in this
account over here and then saving
secretly over here and not doing
retirement it feels like you're trying
to do a lot of things at once I'd love
to see you like okay I'm gonna take 18
months Sprint and pay my house off I'm
gonna pause on on this and I'm gonna get
it done or I'm going to pause and do
this right you see what I'm saying
there's a there's like Rachel said
there's a Finish Line here because I'm
telling you I've just done it and it's
hard it's hard to that Finish Line keeps
moving because it's fun to keep your
whole check it's just future John has to
pay pay that bill right yeah that's a
great Point how much do you make a Nick
I mean make a year Nick
yes so uh between me and my wife
um we're roughly in the 180 to 190 range
okay
um and yeah basically we have 240 left
on our mortgage and then
um I'm I'm projecting that for the next
five years I mean obviously this is
without kids but um as of right now I
can save roughly four grand a month
um in my current situation okay and I
currently have 90 and a 401k and 50 and
just a brokerage account
um so that maybe that gives a little
context
um to where I am yeah for sure yeah
because I mean you could you know within
three or four years like John's saying
focus on that and then take a paid for
home and then even at that point Nick I
would wonder again depending on your
situation with family and everything
once you have it paid off home it is
really nice and maybe you're like oh
yeah maybe just stay in this for for a
little bit longer than what we even
planned on doing that's because what
you're going to do is you're going to
end up putting X number dollars towards
your current mortgage you're gonna put a
little pocket of money for some future
house that you don't live in yet that
you might move into five years from now
my wife and I also we made this big
declaration we're going to start having
kids
and it was almost four years before
um we were blessed with my son and so we
had these plans it just didn't work out
and so I'd love to see you say okay
here's what's right in front of us let's
let's take three years and work like
crazy and pay this house off and then
let's start trying to have a family and
then let's make a decision after we're
holding baby number one because maybe
wife doesn't want to work anymore after
baby number one over here you don't want
to work anymore after baby number one
and you have all these different options
when you have a page for a house you can
do it I mean really you can do whatever
you want and you can sell that house and
Roll All That Equity into a bigger home
if that's what you wanted that's right
that's right yep it's like that savings
is within the home and it keeps you on
plan for the home all right up next we
have Brandon in Orlando hey Brandon
welcome to the show
hey how are y'all doing today doing
great how can we help
good um kind of two different questions
here
um
I'm wanting to know is there some sort
of budget for an unstable income
like I've I hate to admit this but I'm
36 years old and my wife and I have
never really had an actual budget
and we're struggling with this and we
make enough money to sustain our bills
we do have some Consumer Debt we have a
mortgage all these things
um we don't struggle to pay them but our
savings account and checking account
pretty much stay the same all the time
they never go up or they never yeah if I
go down when a bill comes out
Brandon real quick uh I'm up against the
clock so I want to make sure I answer
your question how much does it fluctuate
how like give me like the highest month
and the lowest month for you guys month
um last month I made 24
000 and this month I haven't worked
okay what do you do
I'm a lineman okay
so so there's do you do you know ahead
of time like when you look throughout
the year can you see seasonality of yes
I know these months are going to be
nothing these months are going to be
huge
um some somewhat for for the most part
yes okay so what I would do Brandon is
because it fluctuates that much what you
guys want to do is have a budget that is
consistent and Austin's going to pick up
so you guys can do every dollar uh and
start on that but I have something
that's like hey on our you can't be the
lowest month because it's zero but say
hey here's our expenses here's basically
what we need to live off of and then to
be stocking away when it's these big
months and then when it comes to the
months with nothing you can pull but I
would still keep my my lifestyle to a
degree that's basically just needs so
that way you can at least get momentum
of seeing something move in your
checking account in your savings account
so hold on the line and Austin is gonna
pick up thanks Brandon for the call this
is the Ramsey Show
all right
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney
and we have
our question of the day and our question
is brought to you by neighborly it's
your hub for home services so when you
need to make repairs schedule routine
maintenance or find local help for Home
Improvement projects neighborly is your
source for Reliable home service
providers in your area go to
neighborly.com to start your search
all right today's question comes from
Anthony in Michigan Anthony writes I
just started listening to your show I'm
42 and divorced and I have 73 500 in
Consumer Debt
after making minimum payments rent and
child support I have about 900 left over
it seems like it will take me about six
plus years to get this mess cleaned up
and another one plus years to build an
emergency fund then two to three more
years to save for a house at that point
I will be 53 years old I have zero
dollars for retirement it's overwhelming
and I feel hopeless my question is how
do I hold on to hope as I work through
this debt that's heavy man like I feel
that I feel that oh it's a lot it's a
lot so I mean Anthony honestly this
isn't the
kind nice this is the math side so you
can take the nice relational side of
this John but you know money flows two
ways money flows in and money flows out
and so with this we can't change the
equation that you're in right your your
payments are what they are your rent is
what it is
um you know obviously unless you choose
to live somewhere else child support is
going to be what it is so the biggest
thing that you can affect is your income
and then any other expenses that you
didn't list here but your income is
going to be it and the the way that we
see people move the needle on a large
amount of debt is they go crazy not just
on their lifestyle
but they bring in so much income that
they really do have a diligence to
dedicate that income towards their debt
so Anthony yeah if I were you I would be
taking on a second a third job and again
it's just for a season because if you
could double that 900 a month and do a
side a side gig everything yeah
everything gets cut in half basically
your timeline
um and so working at that because three
years sounds a whole lot better than six
years to pay off the debt and during
that time you're you probably will get a
raise in your current job right or a
boner like things happen in life and you
just designate all that money so I would
be looking to see how can I make an
extra thousand dollars a month or more
and start chipping away at this debt
yeah
because then it's going to free up all
that money to save up your emergency
fund that much faster the hard part
about this job is
um when I feel like
um I'm out of options
then a caller calls in and says hey I on
the way to my the office every day I
pick up an Uber or two and I make 75 or
100 bucks just on the way to work and
then I make 7 500 bucks on the way home
from work and I just do that every day
and
I think yeah but what about my precious
commute time that's just my only me time
this person wants out of debt really bad
or the person who's an exhausted
um single mom who's got two kids who
thankfully has a neighbor that will keep
is working because I'm gonna sacrifice
these two years so I can have all these
other right so yeah I feel like every
day I come to work and there's somebody
else taking away my excuse somebody else
saying no I figured out a way and so I
think Anthony it's really easy to look
at this the way you've laid this out is
actually right it's and it's scary and
it's sad and it's okay to be scared it's
okay to be sad
and then you got to go do the next right
thing and the next right thing is okay
how do I cut this thing in half well
what if we reimagine this where I can
cut it in half and I am done in five
years I'm 47 well I'm done in three
years how much money would I have to
make every month and how can I I will
figure out a way to make this happen
um even if I gotta rent a garage just
sleep in the garage with my friends
whatever like whatever you gotta do
um I I like to see that kind of attitude
and as Rachel said like man we just
there's 30 years of people saying enough
is enough is enough and they do some
wild things they do some wild things
yeah making extra money and again it
sounds so extreme and so crazy but this
isn't forever we're not telling people
to live like this for the next 20 30
years of their life it's literally for
two to three years it's like you're just
gonna buckle down and and anyone can do
it it's exhausting it's hard but we have
people every show but almost every show
on that debt-free stage
screaming and telling their story about
what they've done to get out of debt and
and it looks crazy people think they're
crazy but man that that's the the end
result there is a level of Freedom not
just emotionally and all that but that
Financial part I'm like you just you
have money again you know that that
money is not going out that 900 is not
going out in payments it is staying with
you and so then you're able to scale
back and actually create a life that you
love so thanks so much for the question
that's awesome up next we have Christine
in Atlanta Georgia hey Christine welcome
to the show
hey how are y'all doing today we're
doing great how can we help
okay so I'm a widow recently well a year
and a half ago
[Music]
thank you
um so I wasn't really working at the
time my husband passed because I my mom
died four months before he did and I was
in you know taking care of her so I
wasn't really working but I you know I
do have a real estate license I'm a
realtor so I'm back working now so it's
just slow going so I feel like I made a
mistake when I did get a small amount of
life insurance I did pay off my house
so I am debt free I have no debt uh
except for my monthly expenses which
really concerns me because it's around
four grand and right now I have you know
280 000 in a savings account and a
hundred thousand in a Roth IRA forty
thousand in my checking account but I'm
not making money consistently and I'm
just wanting to know what I need to do
with that
280 000 because it's just a you know
account that's making 3.6 interest rate
do you have kids in the home why are
your expenses so hard
well it's like
it's like all these you know well I've
added in my property taxes like what
that would be for the year I've added in
my HOA even though I pay it yearly I
just did it like what it would be
monthly okay uh you know car insurance
home insurance health insurance I mean
everything starts adding up you know
it's crazy
so all in it's about 48 000. how much
are you making a year doing real estate
I know you're just kind of getting back
but getting back in it so like you know
it's like I haven't even been in it like
really a full year to tell you that sure
well you came back in the whole
industry's on fire right so welcome back
I know exactly so you know like this
month my you know I had four closings it
was twenty thousand dollars next month
it's eight you know it's like eight
thousand dollars or you know eight to
twelve thousand but you know I just have
like a few closings so I don't have like
anything set so I'm just concerned like
what I need to do to maximize I don't
have any kids I just have a dog which is
like a toddler but
um so you know I'm just really trying to
be smart and like you know not wake up
at three o'clock in the morning like oh
my gosh how am I gonna do this because
you know what I mean yes and I think
um
a lot of the fear though Christine is
not is not real we get a lot of calls on
the show where people are in a lot a big
mess financially and that's part of us
helping out you're not Christine I mean
you have four thousand dollars a month
in expenses the numbers you just threw
out was 12 000 a year or twelve thousand
a month for you know I think you said 24
or like you're throwing out these these
these numbers that
Beyond can can pay for your expenses
that's yeah but that's like you know I
it's like Feast your famine you know
with that one yeah okay accept that in
in real estate you're slowly building a
reputation and slowly building a book of
business so my expectation for you would
be
um apps in a complete total housing
market meltdown is that people are gonna
have a great experience with you and
then their friends are gonna call and
that's just I mean I've referred my
um realtor to everyone I know because
she did such a great job for him yeah so
Christine what I would do hold on the
line Austin's gonna pick up and we're
gonna get you in with every dollar to do
a budget but
a savings account and it's an emergency
fund and it's there you're not going to
touch it unless God forbid one month you
need to pull a little bit of cash out to
help cover expenses but that is your
safety net you need some money
designated as a safety net I think to
help you sleep at night to know if
something happens I have that money
there so I hope that helps Christine
thanks for calling this is the Ramsey
Show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual real relationships I am a Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz hosting at this
hour with Dr John deloney and we have a
special guest
this uh this this hour and it's one of
I'm gonna say this and I'm not saying it
just to be nice but genuinely one of my
favorite people on the planet Dr Henry
cloud is with us what's up man hey
welcome welcome and you're here to hang
out with us but more importantly because
you are launching and have launched
yesterday your brand new book trust by
Dr Henry free Cloud knowing when to give
it when to withhold it how to earn it
and how to fix it when it gets broken in
life and business
it's a lot hey there's a lot of promises
there Dr Cloud you are talking to two
people who've got major trust issues and
so I I can't think of a better book that
we got to pick your brain about man you
know I was thinking about your listeners
you know especially that are in the the
uh you know Financial tribe and that
second one when to withhold it
like how many of us have lighter wallets
because of somebody that we shouldn't
have trusted oh absolutely yeah or maybe
you shouldn't have lent it to so the
having a map of an algorithm to check
off the the things that have to be there
to trust and if they're not to not trust
I mean it's it's a big deal it's a lot
because it's a it's an it's a an
integral part if not one of the most
important parts of a relationship right
so whether you're looking at in life
yeah life and business when it God has
wired us literally wired us to trust
because we have to trust in order to get
life from the outside because we don't
have life inside it starts with a baby
and the chemicals start flowing and
you're getting this drug trip and you
trust and you get good things that come
in and we're wired to trust but because
we're wired to trust we're propelled
sometimes to trust people that we
shouldn't be trusting and so it's trying
to get The Head and the Heart working
together and if we have some boxes to
check that that helps so
um in private conversations and I guess
in some public conversations
um people ask me about you know what do
I think the damage that was done to kids
because the masks and schools and this
and that and if I'm being honest and I
step back
when I tell people I think we've got a
hundred year issue it
and and please tell me I'm wrong
I look back over the last three years
and we've lost Trust
in medicine and we've lost trust in
education and we've lost trust in
politics we that concerns me infinitely
more than these day-to-day decisions
that we're trying people are making the
best decisions they got how do we get
this back man I I feel like the epidemic
that is just that where the air we're
breathing is nobody trusts anybody for
any reason about anything anymore right
well
it helps know what we're looking for you
know first of all a lot of people think
well I trust this person or I don't like
it's a toggle switch on or off but
really there's a there's a God's built
in us an algorithm you know right now
we've been trusting the air and we're
breathing you don't even think about it
because your system has been sensing
data and taking it in and coming up with
an automatic yeah breathe then you don't
have to think about it before it reaches
your conscious mind if you smell a fume
before you even smell it your body has
sensed some things and you're going wait
a minute what is that so the the
algorithm inside of us
has got to load on some factors and if
we're going to ever
trust again
it's got to be there's a process that
has to happen forced to hit go because
right now everybody's Hitting off
when they're actually are doctors you
need to talk exactly yeah you know there
are there are this is a place that are
good yes yeah and so we got to get back
but
these things have to be built into the
path back okay and that happens in the
big picture like you're saying but it
also happens cell to cell yeah you know
if divides in families over these issues
or divides you know around the lawmakers
over these issues
if if they're not in proximity really
getting to where they can know why I'm
going to trust this person then it's
just going to stay there so what caused
you to write a book on trust because
usually for most authors they see a
problem yeah maybe that keeps
reoccurring or maybe it's something you
just haven't written about yet but when
I heard when I heard about the book I
was like I wonder just what what was in
your mind like what caused you to want
to write about this topic specifically
well it is similar to that you always
say I don't write books the work writes
the books and and so in war rooms with
CEOs and leaders and you know even in in
family
problems and all of it
if it's a performance issue or it's a
love issue
at some level when you get into
resolving that it is going to call for
either a repair of trust or an
initiation of trust or a qualifying for
trust in order to get to the next step
you can't scale anything in life without
trust I was starting to get on the plane
when I was researching the book you say
what are you working on I said I'm
researching trust and he goes oh I don't
trust anybody I said really he says he
says yeah I learned a long time ago you
can't trust people
he said I only trust myself
I said dude I'm a psychologist and
you're crazy
you say what do you mean I said look out
the window we're forty thousand things
did you get yourself up here all right
you didn't all right you trusted a
couple of pie how do you know the guy
that put fuel on the plane didn't put
chocolate milk in it you trusted it
right right you can't scale life
without trust but I said if I hear your
story though I bet there's been some key
betrayals that have wounded your ability
and now I bet your life is limited in
some ways
so it's a it is a key key key skill
that we have to build in order to make
all of life work whether it's building
them a business or you know having a
relationship yeah so what do you say to
somebody that's like yeah I'm like that
guy on the plane I don't feel like I
trust people and they think back to my
story oh yeah and they could probably
point out some major events minor events
that cause them to be who they are today
uh how do you repair that what do you
well what do you do well
what if you're that person and somebody
said to you well I understand that but
what if we had a map
and if I could give you a map of to look
for these things and then if you saw
those things then you could take the
little bitty next step forward then
would you engage in that and a lot of
times when we have something to hold on
to you know you guys still have people
out there they get a mountain to dead
I'll never get out of debt I'll let you
know
well yeah you will but you got to have
the right steps to take right and it's
not going to happen in a minute but the
process will work yeah it's so good I
think this is such an important topic
will you stay one more segment
absolutely okay let's say and keep
talking about this though because I
think this goes in so much of our life
and our money and relationships as
regards to money within spouses and how
they work together on the subject of
money whether it's their work their life
everything so Henry Cloud Dr Henry Cloud
will be back with us after this break
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz here with Dr John deloney
this hour and this segment we have a
special guest Dr Henry cloud is here
with his new book trust knowing when to
give it when to withhold it how to earn
it
and how to fix it when it gets broken in
life and business and it's blowing up
the charts that released Tuesday and
it's already yep best
on all the in all the categories so uh
awesome absolutely incredible so do you
find okay so even that that subtitle
when to give it when to withhold it do
you find people tend to
find it easier to give it do you find
people it's they or more people withhold
it it's like where do you find like just
general population when you're out
talking is it is it easier for people do
you find more people are willing to give
trust and like all that or do you feel
like people more are withholding
typically you know the people that you
know we call the empaths right they feel
for everybody and oh yeah and they kind
of assume that everybody's like them
like they're loving and responsible so
they just assume everybody well
um read the newspapers I've learned that
lesson the hard way yes look back did
you marry your prom date you know
probably you might have had a misfire
along the way
um so there are a lot of people that do
that and on the other side you know
Rachel
um
people have been burned and so the trust
muscle does get broken in in a lot of
people withhold trust where you know
even take parenting John you've seen
this a thousand times how many teenagers
are kind of starting to act out because
the parents won't trust them where it
would be appropriate right you know or a
marriage or you know how many
micromanaging bosses are there that will
never scale anything because they can't
trust somebody to go do it so it is on
both sides our trust gets it gets
weaponized as as a way to hold power
right right yeah right and and you know
the funny thing is a lot of people it's
a phrase that makes my hair catch on
fire somebody sees something it doesn't
make sense you know maybe their spouse
said they were going to be somewhere
with their son or or an expense report
or you know you said you were going to
this meeting but and the immediate
response is boy you don't trust me
what are you questioning my Integrity
well I wasn't until you said that right
for sure that's all right because we're
not that's a narcissistic entitled
response like I'm entitled to your trust
instead of oh no you know if here let me
show you you know let me because
you know trust really requires that one
party is is helping the other person
make that leap and you're never going to
do it by persuading first and leaders do
this all the time we persuade somebody
yeah this is a great deal you know
you're explaining these things funny
trust starts the first you know I got
five five big boxes to check the first
one is
I'm going to trust you when I understand
that you understand me
um
if I don't know that you have listened
enough to know what I need
and what hurts me and what helps me and
even in a deal
what what I need for this to make it
work for me and you really get that yeah
if I don't feel that and that only comes
through there's a proverb says he who
gives an answer before he listens before
he understands is a fool and it's that's
our culture it that's right how many
conversations it's so true you say
something immediately well you know that
happened to me and it's like a cue to go
talk about themselves yep yep yep
instead of listening I was talking about
the you know the first element of this
in a leadership
perform one time and a guy walks up to
me and says I'm the lead hostage
negotiator for the FBI everything you
just said is our training program he
said if a guy's got a bomb strap to him
and 20 hostages in a bank
we don't walk in and start persuading
him you know saying dude this is a bad
idea you know you blowing up a bit no
that's stupid that doesn't end well
first thing we do is hey I'm I'm Henry
they sent me in here to
talk to you tell me your name yeah and
they get the name and then they ask a
question
so how we get here today yeah
what's going on how do we find ourselves
here
and they're drawing out from them and
once you begin somebody feels understood
their reality validated doesn't mean
that you agree with it but they feel
like you're really getting it then
neurologically starting with the mirror
neurons that an infant has to trust
physiologically anatomically
psychologically emotionally the system
begins to kind of release a little bit
and we move towards
and what we don't want to do is do
something where we hit pause or move
away
and to make any business deal work or
make any relationship work
that's the first one somebody's got to
feel how many times does somebody come
home to a note 10 years of marriage no
says I'm leaving I can't do this anymore
you know good luck and the spouse goes
well what I didn't well they've been
telling you for 10 years
you haven't been understanding yeah yeah
so it starts there and then it goes from
there into some very specific things we
have to look for flip that one around on
me one one of the hardest things I
struggle with personally when I'm
sitting down with somebody and I'm
asking them tell me your story
is their defense mechanism whatever it
may be whether it's addiction or whether
it's not true narcissism but just they
lash out at people
it's well earned oh yeah you got hurt
you got hurt bad
how do you encourage that person who's
metaphorically holding the bomb somebody
you're trying to tell the turtle to
stick their head out and go dude I just
got run over by a truck exactly yeah
um somebody walks in to your world just
just to continue with that story about
the SWAT hostage negotiator and they say
hey man how do we get here
what's some encouragement what's a step
somebody can take when everything in
their body is saying stay inside the
show don't say a word don't say a word
but you know the only path out is trust
you know the only way that this thing
gets resolved with any sort of piece is
I gotta go for I gotta say I gotta I
gotta reach out in some way what do you
tell that person well the first thing
that you've got to do is tell them maybe
without words
you know we are wired and I can't go
into this deeply enough or you know
screaming about enough but we are wired
to trust predominantly in the beginning
apart from words
it's tones it's presence you know one of
the things that's hurt us with all the
remote stuff which you know obviously
it's good for a lot of things to
accomplish stuff and we know that you
know we need but
but when somebody's in the room
and you feel their presence
and the way that that presence is with
you
that does magic
and so sometimes they're not quite ready
for the word so the first thing I would
ask myself is
do they know I'm really with them in
this moment and can they feel that and
you know tone is a big deal yeah yeah
what do you do when you get an email and
one's in caps
Dave never does that Dave never does
that ever the one word Captain the one
word all caps it's like even I I always
say I've trained four German Shepherds
and a Rottweiler and now Doberman and I
love dog training and the first thing my
dog trainer trainer I took dog training
training of course you did and he taught
me was
you know people tell a dog to do
something and then they don't do it and
then they they and then finally say no
what you just taught the dog is well I'm
waiting on the angry one you know the
other ones don't mean anything
but a lot of people think that
um that or don't think about that how
important tone is I mean if you're
trying to get something across to a kid
or get somebody to do something just the
tone can create barriers in their brain
where a it won't work and B they're
moving away from you so I would just
start with that and then then the more
you there's a proverb says a person's
intentions are deep Waters and the
person of wisdom draws them out
and so you've got to begin to get enough
to find exactly what you're said what
what you said
where's the fear and where does the
wound kind of get in the way here so
good so you guys all of that and and so
much more as in Dr Henry Cloud's new
book trust thank you thank you thank you
guys this is a book for me right now we
cannot tell so go online right now and
buy it right now yeah go right now and
get it everyone needs a great story and
then no we got we got four seconds
you need to hear the whole hour this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
okay you guys so we have just two stops
left on our Building Wealth live tour
Salt Lake City you're up next and let me
tell you you're in for a real treats
because this is not just your average
money event we're not going to be
getting all like geeky and nerdy on all
the details of everything we are going
to talk about truly though how to build
wealth in our world today and it's going
to be Dave Ramsey George camel Jade
warshaw and myself and we'll be there
for the entire evening talking about
saving money investing and Building
Wealth no matter what the economy is
doing so right now through April 3rd you
can get some BOGO tickets buy one get
one free two tickets for just 49 or a
pack of four for just 75 so use the
promo code night out to get that deal so
bring a group of friends maybe your
small group at church or just a date
night and George and I are gonna be
kicking off the conversation early so
before the events we're going to be
talking about
um things going on in the world it's
kind of like our smart money it's like a
live version we're smart yeah we're not
really doing we're not doing a podcast
recording though but we'll be answering
some of your questions and hanging out
with you guys before the event and that
is no extra cost just bring your ticket
and come a little bit early for that so
to get your tickets in for the Salt Lake
City Building Wealth event on April 24th
go to ramseysolutions.com events today
up next we have Tyler in Detroit
Michigan hey Tyler welcome to the show
hi Rachel hi John how are you we're
doing great how can we help
oh well I've been struggling a little
bit lately uh sorry I'm a little nervous
no you're fine you're fine
so recently I purchased a house uh in
February and I am going to be a father
in August me and my girlfriend are
expecting a child congratulations new
baby thank you thank you very much I'm
very excited I'm nervous I'm excited
um anyways I'm having a really hard time
budgeting
um I do have some debts
I got a couple motorcycles and then I
have a credit card I need to pay off uh
totaling about 13.5 right now
um I make
about 55 a year and then I do work
overtime so I'm working about 50 hours a
week but
I'm just having a really hard time with
everyone I'm very stressed out because
I'm go go go I get up at four in the
morning I'm working till 2 30 going to
this house and working after and I
started listening you guys about a month
ago and I've been listening every day
um and I just kind of don't know where
to start
awesome well I'm so glad that you called
Tyler so
um will you break down your debts one at
a time for me because you said you had
two was it two motorcycles
yeah so I have one motorcycle that I owe
fifteen hundred and eleven dollars on
left okay
um my other one I owe eleven five
and then on my credit card oh
1320 okay
that's great would you sell one of your
motorcycles or both of those motorcycles
so I'm actually in the process of trying
to do that right now so I'm trying to
sell the one that is uh the higher debt
for me okay
um and partially because I'm going to
gain you know I'm for what I'm selling
it for I'm hoping to get a little money
out of what I paid for it
because I do need to try to save for a
new vehicle I drive an older truck right
now
and one of the doors is not working
anymore and
I need to get well let's hey Tyler let's
do this I want to back out 30 000 feet
here
you how old are you man
I am 26 26. okay
um are you gonna marry this girl
uh that is the plan I I love her a lot
she's a great girl so you've made a
human together and you bought a house
together
uh so I I purchased a house in my own
name okay
so good good my house but it's uh it's
gonna be our home okay for
um for legal purposes let's don't even
touch the morality thing for legal
purposes I'd love to see you say okay
here's an order of importance here I'm
gonna get married and I'm we're gonna
we're gonna start planning for our our
future for our kid for our marriage for
our relationship we have a home now
we're gonna start working on like how
are we gonna budget our money together
right and you're only gonna do that when
you're married but here it feels like
you've got a lot of plates spinning all
over the place I'm gonna try to sell
this thing because I got to get this
thing and then I gotta buy this thing
but I gotta save up for this thing I'm
all over I'm all over the place now I'm
right and it's everything down I'm
stressed out yes yes yes so here's what
we're gonna do a little bit of
relationship stuff and the money and
everything yes I don't know what to do
so Rachel's gonna walk you through the
budget stuff but I can hear that on you
there's just every plate spinning so
when you get off the phone what I'd love
to you do is get a yellow pad get a
piece of paper and I want you to draw a
line right down the middle of it and on
the left side of that line I want you to
write down just take some time and write
down everything that you got going on a
little bit of relationship stuff baby
coming on the way brand new house
haven't the one of the faucets doesn't
work upstairs all that stuff down there
and then to the right of that list I
want you to go through and move over to
the right side of that list everything
you can actually do something about
you can't do anything about the taxes in
Michigan you can't do anything about how
much it's raining or how much it's not
right you can do anything about that
stuff you can go fix that faucet you can
make a budget you can right and so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start controlling what we can control in
a very real way in this list it's going
to feel like the the sky just parted
because it's going to give you some
clarity moving forward okay all right so
back to the dentist that's so helpful
yeah getting stuff yeah Tyler because
even as you're talking it's everything
and I love what John said because it's
amazing when you just put something
Visual and it's just down it's like oh
there's kind of this like and you'll
remember craft tonight you'll be laying
in bed you'll be like oh there's five
more things get up and ride them down on
that paper get up and do it otherwise
they're gonna haunt you and you won't
sleep get up and write them down okay so
money-wise Tyler I think you said
earlier that you had thirteen thousand
dollars in debt but you just gave me you
know maybe four thousand dollars is
there any more debt student loans or
personal loans no so I go to I go to
college right now
um
my work pays for it I'm in I'm in a tool
and die so I'm assumed I uh Apprentice
right now okay so where what else is
left of the 13.
the two motorcycles and then the uh the
credit card which is 1300 now I do have
uh almost 6 800 bucks in my savings but
I don't know if I want to uh put that
towards because of the baby on the way
yeah I hear you
um okay but is there but how does that
that doesn't total thirteen thousand
dollars in debt am I missing something
two of the motorcycles which one is 1500
the other one is eleven five and then my
credit card is thirteen twenty okay yeah
11 500 that's it okay yeah
so we're gonna sell that motorcycle I'm
trying to I'm trying to sell that
motorcycling yes yes okay oh I hear you
it's 11 okay I'm sorry so you're gonna
yeah you'll sell that motorcycle then
you'll only have you'll have about three
thousand dollars left and and honestly
Tyler where you're at we usually tell
everyone to pause the debt snowball you
know pile up some cash
um when is the baby due
August in August okay
so I mean I'm kind of tempted Tyler just
because of where you're at you're a new
listener you're like I just need
traction somewhere there's a part of me
that I'm like just go ahead and pay off
the credit card and with your income
coming in because you have you have a
pretty great income and you're working
extra I'm like man once that motorcycle
is sold and and throw some some cash and
get just a little bit of traction on
this debt I just and selling that
motorcycle is going to do that but
there's a part of me that I'm like God
you could just get rid of all of this I
if I if I were you I would just and just
pay it off and then start saving a ton
because between now and August you can
get a really big savings account and
then what's gonna happen too Tyler if
that's all you're focused on by you pay
off the debt take that 6800 sell the
motorcycle take the 6800 pay off the
remaining debt and then start
stockpiling money and that's the only
goal between now and August Financial
that you're doing is you're staying
current on all of you know your mortgage
payment and all your utilities
everything going on and you're saving up
a massive emergency fund and then one
once baby is good once mom is good then
that's going to be your fully funded
emergency fund and so that's going to
start to help you have traction if you
stay on the line Austin's going to pick
up and we're going to give you Financial
Peace University for a year and every
dollar plus to do a budget because even
those things getting the knowledge and
then doing a budget is going to help you
have a sense of Peace too with to know
exactly where your money's going but you
just need a little bit of direction and
guidance and I think by paying off this
debt it's going to give you some of that
traction and if this is her
propose put a ring on it dude get
married let's do it
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
first Thessalonians 5 21 but test
everything and hold fast what is good
our quote comes from Neil Armstrong
people love conspiracy theories
oh incredible guys and he's been a part
of some so for those of you who don't
know why I'm laughing it's because
Rachel doesn't believe Neil Armstrong
exists I do believe she thinks he's a
cardboard cutout exists but he's
animatronic
man I have seen videos of those
astronauts where people are like on the
moon I saw that video too and they're
like they like punch him and stuff did
you see that no but if I've walked on
the moon like they did actually I would
be upset if people said I didn't walk on
the moon because they went to the Moon
with like a protractor and like uh graph
paper not even with computers and so if
I did all that work which how do you get
to the moon doing that and point exactly
all right that's enough for you good
grief I don't know I don't know oh we
love a good conspiracy America they went
to the moon
they went to the moon all right up next
we have Jade in Dallas hey Jade welcome
to the show
Hi how are you guys we're doing well
thanks for giving us a call how can we
help
so I have
um some student loan debt that I'm
trying to pay off and I'm wondering if I
can use my Rob Ira to do that
the quick answer is a no I would not no
no no no how much debt
53 000 okay how much do you make a year
127 127. Jade you can do this Jake come
on what what what's what was your degree
in
Communications okay
so here's why Jade I we never recommend
pulling out of retirement money to pay
off debt because you're going to have a
lot of you're gonna have a lot of taxes
a lot of fees and honestly it's just
it's not worth it mathematically because
also within your situation Jade you can
do this you can be debt free in 18
months if you if you earn a year you
could cut your lifestyle
all the way down put put half of your
income towards the set and have it paid
off in a year b-a-n-a-n-a-s can you do
that
I think I can I do the thing is I
thought that because it was a Roth IRA
it was already taxed so I wouldn't have
to be penalized if I pulled the
contribution no you still will be
penalized yeah there still are fees and
penalties with that with polling before
retirement age
six ways to Sunday that's a cool hack
you I mean I appreciate the effort there
that's pretty that's pretty good
thinking but yeah they'll kill you man
they'll kill you I would and plus here's
the other thing
um
there's something about
looking in the mirror and say I dug this
big hole and I am going to
um develop new muscles and new Strength
a new character by by working my way out
and there's something about figuring out
let me let me put it this way when me
and my wife had dug such a huge hole
with our student loans and we had to get
real radical about paying them off
we found that we could live with a lot
less and we found we could live in a lot
smaller house than we thought we could
and we we found success looked very
different and that has
a decade later Our Lives look very
different had we someone just came and
waved the magic wand because I never
would have learned that I can what I
really find Value in in life if that
makes sense so you'll discover so much
about yourself by going through this
process that I think is worth it that's
why uh Rachel that's why I tell people
don't I'd rather you pay off the your
loans and don't let the wait for the
government to pay them off because
you're gonna there's a valuable process
that you will go through and getting
that done anyway oh for sure yeah Jade
because we've realized throughout the
years that personal finance so much of
it is about your behavior and like
John's saying if you just magically you
know pull this money out not only
mathematically is it not wise because of
the piece of the the penalties and the
fees but it doesn't change who you are
and there's a process of paying off debt
and sacrificing and changing your money
behaviors that will Outlast this paying
off debt you will have those habits with
you as you go into saving for an
emergency fund you'll have those habits
with you as you fund more into your Roth
IRA and as you start to build wealth
those money habits are going to be the
thing that actually magnifies your
wealth and helps you handle your wealth
versus not feeling that sacrifice at all
so there's something about the Journey
of what happens to you in the process
that John's saying is so so important
that makes sense that makes a lot of
sense and it's going to be hard it's not
going to be easy James it's gonna be the
worst it's not great because what makes
up this 53 000 what kind of debt is it
it's all student loans right it's all
students it's all student loans and uh
you make great money and
you're in the 817 there in Dallas and
everybody drives nice cars and people
are going to look at you that kind of
know what you make and they're going to
be like why are you driving that car or
we're all going out you're gonna say I'm
not I'm trying to pay this thing off and
you're going to be the odd ball out for
one year and then Everything's Gonna
Change or maybe it may be 18 months if
you slow play it a little bit but I
think I think one year yep absolutely
all right Jed you can do this you can do
this all right up next we have miles and
Boise Idaho hey miles welcome to the
show
hey hello thank you so much for taking
my call absolutely how can we help
okay so I've uh you know recently I
started listening to you guys thanks to
a brother of mine and uh my main goal is
to get out of debt obviously my
mentality was that's something that
shifted recently awesome but I find I
find myself in significant amount of
debt
um I'm wondering
uh total with everything I'm at 118 000.
that doesn't include my home yeah is
that does that include your home
it does not it is not okay no in
addition to that would be four hundred
and four thousand for my home okay how
much do you make a year
uh well I just started a business and so
I'm coming in on my second year and last
year we did a 152 000 gross is that what
you made or is that what you took home
no
um I was what I made was closer eighty
thousand okay what makes up the 118
uh so I have five credit cards
and I have five I have three auto loans
I have one uh loan on my equipment that
I use and then I have another uh another
loan on a building that I that I have in
my backyard like I said kind of thing
okay
um so you're just kind of you're just
kind of normal
I'm just kind of normal just kind of a a
American normal got some credit cards
some
right a shed in the back
how much is your mentality my mentality
up to this point has been well it fits
into my monthly budget I can afford it
monthly right and so yeah like I said
I've had to shift that mentality and now
I kind of feel like I'm drowning and
being that I'm two years into business
this was the first winter that I came
into or work slowed down significantly
and now I really feel you're feeling it
yeah how much is your mortgage payment
on that on that 404 000.
twenty three hundred dollars okay well
that's not you know for an 80 000 income
that's not
um outrageous uh as ratios because we
want it to be about 25 of your income
um being towards your mortgage payments
um so Miles I mean honestly what I would
look at if I were you
um is I would list everything out and I
would say what can I sell today what can
I sell we have three vehicles we got we
got crap around our house that were
probably bought on these credit cards
that we don't need can my wife sell
stuff online uh we're taking TVs off so
like we are going crazy because here's
the deal miles you guys have just been
living what you feel in the moment and
you just kind of keep going and Trucking
and it's caught up with you and so now
you're at this point where you're
thinking holy crap what have we done
what are we doing and so you have to
have a level of an extreme change to
start to feel some traction so if again
if I were you I would be selling
everything possible liquidate as much as
you can to get some of the this 118 Dan
I mean how much is it on the cars total
all three cars how much of that is 118.
on the three cars I'm at forty thousand
okay with all three total
yes yep and then I have 25 000 on my
equipment that I run
um and do you need that for your
business
I do yes all right another thing if
you're running your business out of your
home checking account that's a whole
other issue man you need to separate
those expenses out you got to pay your
debt off but
man if you're running this stuff through
your home budget your create you're
going to create all kind of chaos for
you for your taxes for your business for
all of you yeah separating now it's
going to be important so yeah miles I
mean honestly I would go scorched Earth
everything to attack this debt and
you're going to start to see the light
at the end of the tunnel especially if
you go extreme and you sell some if you
sell this stuff you work extra you guys
go all the way in it's going to be
amazing amazing what happens with the
progress so thanks so much for listening
and thank you America thanks all the
guys in the booth thank you John for a
great show this is the Ramsey Show hey
it's Rachel Cruz if you love this show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the Ramsay way
just go to ramseysolutions.com today to
sign up for our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]